one time he was supposed to be here he
was like I'm sick I'm not feeling well
yeah but he was that he was deathly ill
actually he was like not feeling good
this morning what should I do but I
don't want to like let you guys down and
all that you already did but with this
text so they just stay home
and I'm always like there's nothing I
want to do less than let the boys down
you're like it's okay and he's like okay
cool I'll see you guys when it comes to
feelings I'm the worst person to text
I'm like bro my dad died and I still
came obviously that's like an unbeatable
thing you have yeah it's an unbeatable
you're gonna hold that over us yes Amber
can be like man my dad didn't just die
either I'll tell you that
[Laughter]
that much
foreign